III 2019 it's gonna be a weird show we
have no more Sony but still a bunch of
companies are gonna be there very
excited to see what they bring
what are your hottest predictions let's
start with EA well let's get all the
sports games out of the way first those
are boring not for everyone ultimate
team but it's also like not really a
prediction every year there's always
there's those FIFA is that it yeah there
was mad in I think it's a fair shout
that we'll see a lot more of apex
legends season two potentially hopefully
they do something more interesting than
season one because that battle Passman
it wasn't very good I think I think
they'll have learned their lessons I
guess yeah yeah just have some fun with
it
like maybe maybe don't go too crazy like
fortnight but like I don't know some fun
challenges to do in the map yeah
I'm ready for new Legend a new Legend
yeah I feel like that has to happen yeah
if they're like rumors of being a second
one this season that was like that I
don't remember what it's called Watson
or something was leaked a while ago so
here like season two is probably the
time to release that one yeah cuz octane
was a great addition but also I was
watching like a shroud video the other
day and he said oh I was playtesting
this character almost a year ago this is
kind of wild how far in advance they
have to plan that yeah
so if Watson has been in the loop for so
long and pushing in
is the best option and I gave up on ants
like no I don't think they gave up on
anthem but I do think that I mean
recently by our said like a we got
changed our roadmap right so maybe this
is a good time for them to kind of lay
the groundwork for a this is our new
vision for anthem so yeah they're their
roadmap that they kind of came out with
release was pretty vague it was like
then there's a cataclysm then there's a
there's this and it's like I don't
really know what these things are
yeah I assume the game will have some
sort of presence because again yeah he's
not really doing that sort of like
traditional stage show so I think that
gives maybe by where like room to
breathe and you like it we're just gonna
have like a casual stream or we talk
about this stuff room to scramble
maybe sure I guess if they're gonna be
talking about anthem maybe Dragon Age I
don't think they're gonna talk about
Jack maybe they'll just like mention it
by name say hey dragon wage attraction
wage dragon age is in the works like
just to remind you please have faith in
us we're still making that game that you
want yeah that would actually be
comforting to hear yes sir during what
happened with anthem right like I think
if anthem was a success I wouldn't be
soon not that way I don't know I think
if the circumstances were different I
wouldn't need to hear more about that
game yeah but because of how messy
anthem is and how like you were saying
maybe they might call with a new roadmap
kind of free like figure out what they
exactly want to do with that game long
term yeah yeah be nice to hear like yeah
don't worry we're still thinking about
the Dragon Age don't worry still
percolating on it Oh Jedi for motor
that's I think that's the big that's the
big boy do we know we know we know that
gameplay is gonna be there or we're
gonna see it in action
yes it's coming I mean it's not that
long until it's actually coming out
after e3 right what November
but guess we will get to see it in
action and I don't know I think if I
were to make you prediction based on
gameplay or whatever I'm almost feeling
that this is gonna be closer to a Jedi
Knight Jedi Academy sort of style of
game which I really hope it is because
that those games were really good and I
think it can really channel a lot of
that same same energy big big Jedi yeah
expect a lot really trying to think of
one that's good I like that
I think they got to make a really damn
good Star Wars game at this point yeah
she told my path is des so do eternal
it's pretty much I mean a good chunk I
imagine if that presentation is gonna be
too intense
I was watching the presentation from
quake on last year and like I'm sorry I
need to see more like yeah yeah yeah me
too I think that they're doing a lot of
cool tricks and stuff based on what we
saw previously like it's not just an
iteration on like doom 2016 it's like
now they're doing a lot of different
things so what I think when it comes to
eternal like the some of the the
multiplayer aspects not necessarily like
the competitive multiplayer stuff but
like how they're integrating that kind
of map right you can play as like a
demon in your friends game but you
getbut like you drop into someone else's
game but you can turn off and you just
want to play by side almost like Dark
Souls yes yeah the player style you have
been invaded by yeah by oh no big big
that's what I'm saying though so what
else are they gonna have you're gonna
see anything from fallout
I'm saying like I have to go great I'm
stating that so I think we will I think
they're gonna keep it short
I have no indication of whether or not
this is true but I think it would go for
you play and I assume that if they won't
really want to sustain fallout 76 if
they're serious about that game I mean
maybe a free-to-play model works I mean
they have that what atomic shop are they
yeah by a bunch of stuff so they can
make their bank there but I mean I don't
think they're gonna be like selling
any more copies of that game to be
honest no then I'm talking about star
fields and then I was talking about
Elder Scrolls 6 mmm arcane whatever no I
don't think that arcane is in the
process of at least we don't know what
can see gotta be working on some things
in spray yeah and and they they even
splits to like they arcane is
technically two Studios they have
awesome young and then Leon also
Leone I don't know man I would love to
see something for marking but I think if
we do I don't think it'll be another
dishonor now it's got to be something
new as much as I love those games I feel
like they don't typically sell as well
as it breaks my heart I know but I think
Bethesda knows that they have a very
talented team in arcane so I my guess
would be new new IP and see what they
can do and maybe I don't know bring back
resurfaced something from their past and
of course you got Wolfenstein which is
coming out straight after e3 yeah I
can't imagine they'll show much more
than a trailer maybe like a little bit
of gameplay but it's out soon mmm-hmm
alright Ubisoft is this gonna be a
watchdogs year or an assassin's creed
year or see corruption 3 yeah please
finish tell us go under so year I don't
think it will be though you know that
Judah and Garrity from the division
doing that tweet like just mean it was
so mean it was like the Futurama you
raised my hopes and - than quite at
least so mean like I I think what in
their earnings call they say that they
have two games that will come out this
year that they haven't announced yet one
was Ghost Recon which has been announced
yeah and then they have another one that
we assume will be at e3 mm-hmm
Assassin's Creed has been leaked it's
supposed to be like Viking Assassin's
Creed Ragnarok is is that the team that
did the lag in origin I think so and
then there's that other game which could
be watchdogs could be Splinter Cell I am
holding out for Splinter Cell
yeah I know man watched watch dogs sold
hell of a la yeah it might be the
origins team might be doing whatever
this Assassin's Creed
I guess Ragnarok is what ya call it
because they are on a three-year cycle
when it comes to assess discrete games
yeah so I guess that makes sense and
then just dance game be it every single
III conference until the end of time yay
Beyond Good and Evil 2 is something that
they've been talking about what is what
is maybe we'll find out at this e3 oh
alright so we've had you be Square Enix
holding another press conference see you
guys I don't know hey I mean like Final
Fantasy 7 has to be yeah after the sony
state of play i'll be bold and say that
5 5 to 7 remake episode 1 because
remember there's gonna be an episodic
thing yes I go into a thing they go and
whole bit on it they're doing one game
in two three yeah so maybe they're gonna
now it's a release for episode twenty
twenty I'm saying this year but I
shouldn't be saying that
so all maybe like spring 2020 I have no
idea how they've been working on that
game especially considering no Morris on
being on Kingdom Hearts up until you
know like February of this year
like dude when is he had time they even
announce it before Final Fantasy 15 came
out so like who knows in the year of
endgame we have to see avenge right
that's they have the Avengers game yeah
that's Crystal Dynamics and they've been
stepping up they announced that a few
years ago and we sold that one teaser
and then heard nothing Babylon's Falls
also another thing that they had teased
last year's at the Platinum that's
Platinum Games published by Square and I
think the the lead guy who did Bayonetta
2 and scalebound not a commie of the
other dude forgot his name but he's
leading that project so I think that
it's will be dope to see something from
him and obviously they announced it last
year and it still said on squarings
website that it's coming in 2019
still coming so yeah what about the
quiet man - what's the water you know
what I hope we left field choice it
would be fly man
- as in - the score I got no I think I
got one
I think it goes like it 304 Nintendo so
Mari make it - we know a lot about that
we know about that I didn't go see it I
don't think we'll see much of it the PI
be like Oh a reminder Mario becasuse
yes maybe like a short trailer just
because we had that 15 minute direct
what a week ago I think they did that
just because they were like we're gonna
get this out of the way because we have
big announcement I think it's about this
year I think we have to get a release
date for that yeah yeah I mean obviously
it's gotta be fall at this point yeah
September October maybe do you think
we'll see anything from Bayonetta three
that's what I was doing I was that's
what I'm hoping for
at least to remind us that yeah that
that's in the works you've reminded us a
lot of really not enough yeah no no no
they've been like Dory we're still
working on it and it's like yeah well
didn't show us something police so I
predict that they will say that again
yeah and they won't show us anything no
maybe we got like a 10-15 second teaser
yes seeing Bayonetta again whatever a
new style that she's like a new haircut
it's like yeah exactly I'm gonna see her
new haircut because like the thing is in
2017 what metroid prime 4 was apparently
in development yeah
all they did was like that ten-second
like splash screen and I was like yo I
lost my stuff they do it they do the
same thing for being at 3 I'm like dude
I'm gonna lose me so speaking of Metroid
Prime for development has been restarted
so I don't expect to see at all yeah do
we imagine it's gonna like the old games
gonna come a switch in the meantime but
they could do but like a Metroid Prime
for is coming out like how many years
from now but hey you want to catch up on
the trilogy because it's been so long
how about
Metroid Prime trilogy on this every
direct
there's always a rumor that Metroid
Prime trilogy is coming the switch
there's always someone who says it and
it is never happy
well it's gonna be me it's gonna be this
thing it's gonna be this yes if I want
it to be but I I'm just like like I
don't know I hope it's coming but I'm
I've kind of lost hope just because
every direct the rumor is is that we're
gonna get Metroid Prime and people are
so confident that we're gonna get it too
though I'm not I mean Tendo must see
that and must kind of go pop we're sat
on a veritable gold mine and it's intend
on Nintendo's like huh we're sitting on
a golden baby gonna sit on it ten years
yeah they can pretty much call their own
shots so I don't think they're like too
concerned about what other people are
thinking I think we'll probably see more
of Fire Emblem three houses we already
kind of got a direct of that that they
talked pretty in-depth about it in early
state should come out in July I don't
think we'll see a whole lot but I
imagine we will see more mechanics yeah
hopefully someone mechanics me gameplay
trailer but also Nintendo also has
Asheville chain in the works so that's
another Platinum Games join so platinum
is making babylons fall with Square Enix
but Asheville chain is the project under
Nintendo and that's headed up by the
combat designer for Nier automata talkie
cetera and yeah that's when out this
year as well so and but and when it was
first revealed there wasn't that much we
got glimpses of gameplay but I think
before it comes out this year I want to
see more of what that game is how plays
what the storyline actually is so I
think that'll be maybe a big part of
Nintendo's e3 presence I guess all eyes
are gonna be on Microsoft this e3 Sony's
kind of moved out of the picture they're
gonna go big do you think we're gonna
get that first look at hardware they
keep bringing it up they keep bringing
it up that I working on it and stuff is
leaked there's rumors of speculation
anaconda and scarlet yes I think it's
the coaster they called X no that was I
don't remember anyway yeah then the to
rumor cause I think we have to I think
especially after Sony kind of just like
told everyone what's inside yeah it's
very casually by the way yeah and I
think Microsoft is gonna make a big show
of it yeah because last year
zhan there's like oh but by the way like
new hardware's on the way peace out
charlie so I think like this here like
hey remember when you said that there's
a hardware let's let's take a look at
least let's sneak peek into what that
actually is because I mean the ball is
in their court in terms of like you know
Sony Microsoft so this would be the time
to do it really but it also makes you
think about where a project x cloud fits
into the picture so yesterday did they
introduce that last year they went a
little deeper on it on an inside Xbox
recently and now they have this merger
with Sony where the two companies are
actually working together on cloud
solution I imagine X cloud is gonna get
hopefully a better name yeah I imagine
that is a placeholder for what this is
but could you imagine if they introduced
that within you know your xbox live
subscription so you get game pass you
get Xbox Live and you get access to X
cloud that would be to be unreal that
would be yeah make with that huge
library so we have Hardware last year
they made a huge show about new first
party acquisitions so people like Ninja
Theory playground games we're gonna see
anything from those or is it going to be
too soon I think it'll be too soon for a
lot of them but I think we I think we
will see things from some because I
imagined before Microsoft acquired
playground games they're probably
working on an exclusive what do you know
that secret favor that everyone just
assumes this fable but yeah yeah I would
like them to just even hinted that I
would to just to show a future with like
especially with our new console coming
out even if they're just some short
teaser trailers of yeah what could be
coming like I'd like to see what Ninja
Theory is working on the show and with
obsidian a part of Microsoft we already
know that they're doing the outer worlds
but I think like that's cross-platform
though right that is false platform but
of course like Microsoft is not a
stranger to having third-party games
obviously yeah on there but they're like
in the midst of being a first party so I
would expect an extended kind of look at
the out
old Scalise that is one that I'm very
interested yeah I'm interested not to
give is kids is coming out this year
right
Oh Annie I hope so they showed quite a
bit last year didn't they yeah yeah a
minute I think this yeah they're talking
about multiplayer more is that there's
some like in sports competition towards
the end of the week so I imagine look at
that halo gotta show more last last year
was such a tease it was like it's gonna
hold my helmet and yeah yeah I think
that obviously halo Infinite is still a
ways off I don't think it's gonna be
2020
definitely is your course in but yeah
just like what is the nature of this
thing is it a kind of infinite game
that's like a survival base thing that
never ends is it an MMO fps or is it a
battle royale like you don't know what
is the infinite dimension battle royale
fit doesn't like people to like it when
you mention hey limbo around yeah no no
no no really I I think it'll be I
imagine be more of a platform I think it
all launched on this current generation
and it all Spann - it'll be supported
throughout whatever the next console is
like a destiny whoa I think so but maybe
a little more tied together like I don't
imagine maybe the direction this
generation is heading I could see like
maybe cross lay with me - like with the
Xbox one and whatever the anaconda is or
whatever more of a games as a service
approach for Halo I I can see something
like that in Halo like if that if that
infinite sub name means anything I guess
yeah and I suppose last year third-party
close that Microsoft it was cyberpunk
we're gonna see more yes that's where
accountable they've already said yeah
their Twitter accounts like yeah we'll
be there
I think we're gonna get a release date
for it and I think it's gonna be fall
and I think it's definitely I think it's
gonna get - well you're thinking like
two steps ahead yeah I think I think
they're gonna say I I don't know October
November fall and then it's gonna get
pushed and it's good come on spring okay
this is like this is in my mind the best
scenario though I feel like it'll be
like oh yeah that's coming out in like
2022 I'm like damn but this is this is
me hoping yeah yeah I mean we last year
was a very large chunk of that
like fifty minutes of nothing so you
know if they come out with another hours
worth of gameplay like I'm down with
that but going back to like think about
release date though I think like that's
what everyone talks about with this game
because now we've saw that we've seen it
in action and I think like not too long
ago they said like hey this game is
basically playable from start to finish
right so I mean people is thirsty out
there
Jake's thirsty for that - I'm thirsty
for that game I would I watched the the
45 minute thing again like a week I
didn't do it
I'm not holding my breath for that but
like the best-case scenario in my head
is that they're like and it's coming out
and fall whatever month and if you look
at sight that's the wrong release date
and yeah we'll probably see more dying
light - yeah that had like to the
streets - that had a really good showing
last year it was kind of out of nowhere
it looks very ambitious not that nothing
like one wasn't but it was kind of buggy
and like sure yeah some of its IDs were
only like half thought out I mean still
a phenomenal like it was a phenomenal
game and all the DLC was great and it
was my politics so yeah like I think
last year they had put out a battle
royale mode which is actually really fun
yeah yeah it was pretty good but it
seems like after the success of dying
light one it seems like they're really
putting their resources into dying like
to to make it something really really
unique like the faction system in that
game seems to be pretty cool so it makes
definitely excited to see more of that
Chris everyone's watching this story and
Christmas story yeah I love me some
Chris Avalon story stuff some
world-building
yeah some law oh yeah and there's also
been the rumor the world while this
rumor that george RR martin has been
consulting with from software on a game
that has horses in it yeah
interesting considering Sakura just came
out yeah Miyazaki's attached to it so so
busy math they do kind of have like two
teams right like I have to went to Dark
Souls 3 though I've been blood-borne him
and Miyazaki's team which did Secura so
maybe it's that other team yeah but
people are rumors that we'll see it at
e3 which seems like a little too soon
yeah it's full HD but it's like what
kind of game is that this stuff floating
around that's like open-world Norseman I
don't know like it's super hard to say
like there are rumors out there but
nothing nothing really to latch on to I
think I don't think it'll be like Dark
Souls or blood-borne like they seem like
they want to kind of step away from that
SEC euro is different in some sense but
it's still shared a lot of similarities
I wouldn't be surprised if they try to
take a huge departure from those moves
maybe something more open but yeah
there's not much there's a living
seriously not allowed to go from also
behind if it is Norse mythology then
you've got assassin's creed whatever you
have God of War 2 and now this is like
games is like that's the new trend
what's the new trend yeah NORs horse is
screw battle royale yeah
alright so final predictions ultimate
pie-in-the-sky wild Cod what would you
love to see appear at e3 rockstar 10 if
he doesn't share anything but like I
don't say it you're gonna say what do
you say write the DLC Oh dad they lost
that weight what camera is the camera
agents dead anyway no I I really hope we
see red story read the DLC yeah I feel
like the online is not really picking up
as much as GTA online did they're at a
beta 2 so they kind of like I guess said
their piece more or less
and I think that people are hungry for
more red bed and there are so many
stories left to tell just from Red Dead
red dead - as is that story there I
think there's so much more they could go
from there
but Rockstar is like famously almost
they they never showed you three sides
now that is definitely a pie in the sky
for me my eyes are on Warner Brothers
because they are sitting on rumored to
be sitting on some projects that I'm
super interested in whatever the hell
Rocksteady are doing so when was Arkham
night was about 2015 2014 to 15 15 what
have they been working on what a Warner
Montreal working on they've been
staffing up like crazy there were rumors
of you know a Suicide Squad project as
rumors of a cancelled Damian Wayne
project which pretty cool and then there
is the Harry Potter RPG that leaked last
year which looked too real to be like
some dude in his basement
like just making it to fake out of the
Internet that was way too much about
that game wasn't it wasn't like it
supposed to be a cancelled Harry Potter
game or something
no it's meant he said the guy who leaked
it was like oh I was doing some market
research about Harry Potter game it's
you know I'm like no and but he did like
off-screen filming it's an RPG you get
to align yourself with being a good guy
or bad guy and I would obviously go
Slytherin but it's you know I mean it's
Lutheran is automatically a bad guy I
mean they have and snakes do everything
but I mean just because all the Harry
Potter games bar you know the Lego ones
have just been these really tedious
tie-ins that have never been very
exciting yeah they don't really
understand what makes those no movies in
books so good
yeah and so if you're gonna take
something like Harry Potter and make it
dark especially because we're the
generation that grew up with Potter and
so like we're adults now we don't need
to relive the
airy-fairy first couple years of high
bar again I want the hard [ __ ] I want to
be killing goblins and fools
alright I will make a kind of serious
issue prediction because I know damn
well ain't no persona sakes coming
anytime soon
but you know Square Enix has their own
more or less press conference or
whatever so yeah we had already
mentioned that maybe the Avengers game
is gonna be there they have a new
platinum game what if they got a new new
thing from Yoko taro like I don't know
what he's up to like he's still doing
something I don't know he's doing work
for with Final Fantasy 14 for there for
Shadow bringers he's doing a mere themed
dungeon but oh I don't know I feel like
Square Enix is like keeping him in the
loop because maybe he's still involved
doing something maybe now's a time like
Nier automata came out in 2017 so it's
been a little time since then maybe we
can get an update on what your potaro is
up to fingers crossed it's gonna be a
weird year but I'm kind of cautiously
optimistic about it yeah hey there do
you like video games of course you do
and you should totally head over to
GameSpot calm and proves all of our
fresh III content everything from
gameplay hot off the show floor to
insightful interviews from the
developers of the games that you love
even live streams of the press
conferences themselves we'll be right at
your fingertips you won't miss a single
announcement what are you waiting for
come on by
[Music]